noël à moscou qui vient de refuser ya
quelques instants toute négociation sur
l'ukraine avec l'union européenne et
l'ouest et aux fins de non-recevoir
formulée par sergueï lavrov alors que
l'elysée qu'on vit aujourd'hui à paris
les conseillers diplomatiques des
présidents russes ukrainiens et du
chancelier allemand des discussions à
quatre pays dans le format dit normandie
dans l'espoir de parvenir à jouer les
médiateurs dans le conflit en cours
emmanuel macron veux ton corps tenter
une carte diplomatique
même s'il a prévenu hier une agression
russe en terre ukrainienne sera synonyme
de riposte européenne écouter le
rhin et change vendredi matin avec le
président poutine ce n'est pas un
déplacement ce sera un échange
téléphonique qui aura pour but de faire
un point sur l'ensemble de la situation
et d'essayer de justement obtenir de la
visibilité
engager un dialogue exigeant et obtenir
des clarifications sur plusieurs des
points en cas d'agression et comme cela
a été dit s'il devait y avoir une
agression
la riposte sera là et le coût sera très
élevé